speaking of drivel nonsense
arguably my greatest segue ever here's
the view
and there are trump donors who are now
giving to desantis meaning they're
giving to his quote re-election campaign
right for governor but they know he's
raising much more money than he's
actually going to need for the
governor's race and as a result he's
going to have this huge war chest at the
end of this re-election campaign guess
where that's going to go you were saying
he's got about 200 million he's going to
have about 200 million probably by the
time of the election he's got 125 people
giving money to these people well and by
the way sunday is a good point for folks
who aren't familiar what a lot of these
these apps and websites do is you click
to give once and it actually signs you
up to recurringly give it is so unfair
it is a great
okay
do we have to do desantis 101 he kept
the state open
florida is thriving he is defending free
speech he is stopping the ever
encroaching federal government he's
making sure we don't get flooded with
illegals he is doing all of the right
things like if you got a checklist the
right things bam he's just checking them
off every day that guy goes to to bed
and puts his head on the pillow knowing
that he did good work on any given day
and i i'm telling you i'm meeting so
many people here of every walk of life
that are so appreciative of desantis and
being in florida and doing it right so
they're upset that he's raising money
now why is he raising money now first
off he doesn't need 200 million dollars
to to win his re-election here obviously
he's running against this guy charlie
chris charlie crist used to be governor
of florida he was a republican governor
of florida years ago now he's a democrat
he's also a closet case people used to
talk about that but now i guess they
don't talk about it anymore he has
absolutely no support he's an
inauthentic
weirdo he's just there's nothing there
so desantis obviously is going to crush
it and i would say in many ways desantis
already is the president of the united
states in a certain regard uh he's not
president by title but he's president in
terms of the president is supposed to be
the leader of the country and if america
is still a free nation that is ruled by
law and uh the founding documents and
all those things then ron desantis
basically is the president already um
but they're so obsessed with this guy
because the meme has gone out to the
media right now it's very obvious what
has happened there was an article in the
new yorker that basically was saying uh
it's by this guy jonathan chait another
one of these kind of trump deranged
people who gets everything wrong but you
know in lefty world you always move up
uh how ron desantis is actually worse
than trump because he's got all the
policies of trump but he's competent so
it's like competent hitler the other one
we had was stupid hitler now we got
competent hitler that is going to be the
meme on desantis for sure oh my god he's
staff's right he knows what battles to
fight to fight he doesn't have the
personal baggage and all that stuff so
he's got all the good trump stuff and
he's functional oh dear lord what are we
gonna do uh but what's interesting about
that video of those ladies on the view
is that that girl
that's sitting on the right over there
alyssa farah she was in the trump
administration okay so she was in the
trump administration but now she is
making a career going after trump going
after republicans she's the perfect pet
republican right these people that go on
msnbc they go on the view they get pat
on the head they get a cookie and they
have no shame and she dare calls ron
desantis a grifter the people that are
giving ron desant this money are they're
giving him money because they actually
it's money well spent it's a rare moment
where actually giving money to a
politician is money well spent because
you are helping someone strengthen their
ability to defend you not rule over you
it is a distinction that is lost on
these clown people but anyway this alice
alyssa farrow who is now becoming a
media darling she's on cnn and she's on
the view and she throws all of her
former colleagues under the bus and she
pretends she has nothing to do with
trump and all of those things well she's
getting a sort of nice moment with the
mainstream media but
she doesn't realize that they are going
to destroy her too and sonny's sort of
trying to tell her very curious as to
alyssa's opinion on this because she
probably knows bannon and all the other
crazy people she used to work with so
i'm very curious as to what you think
deal with the devil lady that's what you
signed you signed a deal with the devil
they will keep you around while you are
useful and the second they are done with
you oh you were a trump person you
ushered all this in blah blah blah so
good luck on your little contract for
the next year or so but this will not
end well for you alissa farah but if you
want to do the show and talk about it
i'm all ears